if buying a super yacht seems exciting
imagine being able to sketch the design
of glass elevators and onboard private
bars selecting the hardwood of internal
stairs and the fabric and color of soft
furnishing and interiors welcome to the
ultimate custom-built luxury experience
the bespoke super yachts for those who
don't have to worry too much about the
budget you're building a dream here so
how much you've been prepared to build
to spend on your dream sky's the limit
Fraze yachts is one of the brokerage
companies dealing with the construction
sale and customization of luxury Benetti
boats more than 30 meters in length and
worth at least 10 million euros the
yachtsman tailor-made experience starts
in this showroom at the Bonetti shipyard
in tuscany this is where they really
start to choose what their interior is
going to look like so we're surrounded
by hundreds of samples in terms of wood
veneers carpets leathers loose furniture
cutlery crockery glassware towels it
really is a wonderful playground phrase
yachts has clients from over 50
countries and demands vary by region
people from the Middle East will have
larger interiors as well people from the
Far East Europeans and Americans will
have larger deck spaces when it comes to
the external features of the boat some
trends are definitely invoked the
exterior designs we're seeing larger and
larger windows which means that much
more natural light is coming into the
yacht it also means that once you're
inside the yacht you've got much nice
views to the outside nowadays Frazee
yacht says the younger the client the
bolder the customization the new
generation you see a younger generation
you have to adapt to their requirements
so I think I have to go in for water I
see people that probably utilize the
boat for much more interesting a
proposition like traveling around the
world or in boat is that they can have a
bigger toys to carry or bigger tender
more autonomy less cost in certain cases
they stay more about the boat but
especially they like to travel
extensively for this type of approach
who you needed to have a much more
customized board getting carried away
though might prove a huge mistake
particularly if you consider your boat
as a win but as an investment on the 100
you're building your dream without
thinking that one day you might want to
sell there and hopefully by a larger
yard so that it's finding that balance
between what's what you like but also
considering what the market may like
sergey cheese when you choose that the
seller yacht
[Music]